hi there here i am
in my
i guess the sixth day here in argentina
so i will update you i'm in the backyard
of this lovely
bed and breakfast that we're staying at
in mendoza mendoza is the capital of the
wine
industry here in argentina
so we flew out of the call at the
municipal airport in buenos aires which
was a absolute pandemonium situation
because i don't know whether their
systems were down or their pilots were
on strike or whatever
but it was just a mad scramble we
got to the airport at 8 15 we finally
flew out at one o'clock
very happy to get on a plane
and flew across the country due west
towards the mountains right here in
mendoza you're basically
just in almost the foothills of the
andes you can see the andes mountains
with their snow-capped peaks
very nice i would say gives the
impression of being a quiet city
um
on the flight over i bought a book in
spanish on the history of argentina and
i love reading
about history and so it's quite
interesting to realize that argentina
didn't develop from buenos aires moving
west say the way north america developed
from the atlantic coast moving west
in fact there wasn't much they were very
it was very sparsely populated in the
plains of argentina whereas the old inca
empire
was based in cusco which is in the
mountains in peru
and of course the spanish administration
was based in lima
so it was more and the mines were up
there potosi and so forth so it was more
the
the effect of that
you know uh populist base sort of
expanding
eastward into what is now argentina
and then with the development of the
mines then
you know these communities that
developed in argentina
near mendoza for example were supplying
to
the mines and that was the sort of
business activity
until uh the late 19th century when
agriculture and railroad and all this
expansion happened in argentina which
really gave impetus to to buenos aires
at least that's what i've been able to
glean so far from reading my book it's
also good for my spanish i have to
confess i haven't been doing any
arabic
um
[Music]
yes today we visited a
vineyard a winery and had a fabulous
lunch and sample different wines
um
once you get out of the big cities
uh
things are pretty simple pretty slow
paced here in argentina
low slung houses
um
you know
easy pace
pleasant people
and of course i have a cousin who lives
here
and so we were also at their place last
night
my cousin and her husband and
son and of course i'm traveling with
another couple and they cooked up a
barbecue at their home outdoor barbecue
so
we have had a lot of beef at this point
and we don't need to see any beef for a
while because we have had beef every day
good beef but enough is enough
uh
it's interesting you know the
husband of my cousin here
he has a business uh
he has
software engineers here in mendoza
in
colombia in peru
and he works for mostly customers in
the united states
and uh it's interesting talking to him
of course he's been to india he's been
to ukraine
and it's all part of this global world
i'm a very strong globalist i know that
today in politics you know there's a
sort of pro-globalist anti-globalist i
think it's pointless to be
anti-globalist we're going to be
increasingly globalist the world is
getting smaller
we are connected people are doing
business so here in argentina you know
and that's what's so much fun about
traveling is you start to get a visual
perspective like i was in greece or i
was in israel and in jordan and
in ukraine and so what do these
countries look like previous to that i
was russia and czech republic and
and myanmar and vietnam and so you get a
sense of this world and the world is
very small and very connected
interconnected as i explained earlier
when i had to get my brazilian visa
produced again and how via the internet
connecting with
india
to reproduce a past a visa that i'd
obtained through the brazilian embassy
in ottawa and i get it at the staples
operation here in buenos aires and stuff
this is the world we live in we're very
intimately connected with each other so
the issue is not a
globalism good or bad the issue is how
do we make it better how do we make it
sort of so that opportunities more equal
for people those are the issues but to
be against globalism to me is is
childish
i think we have to go out and
discover
more and more of our world and how
we are all connected and how can we
live together in better harmony those
kinds of things
anyway it's fun to be here
tomorrow we will still be in mendoza
then we go back to
buenos aires to do some more things
then some tango hopefully
maybe visit a estantia where they have
gauchos who knows i don't know what
we're gonna do and then we're on to
iguazu in brazil
okay that'll update you for now people
wanted a long longer v-log i would do
this in the street there but it's so
noisy i thought it would be better to
retreat back here to the garden
bye for now
[Music]
you